[Music]
fire sheriff horgan
1984
uh one of many games in which caspar
have beat gm alexey shuroff
um who of course was also one of the
world's
top players in the 1990s you can see
2740 which by those standards was
insanely high um and more meaningful
than it is today
so we have a ceveshnikov
which begins as a e6 sicilian but
transposes into a seven cup now this
fashion cup
is an opening which has existed actually
much longer than people realize
it was first played in the year 1883
which is actually quite odd when you
think about it black weakens the d5
square
you know in the 19th century they or
were a lot less keen on
violating principles of this sort so
it's actually impressive that so many
players caught on to this so we dropped
the knight back to a3 i think a lot of
you are probably familiar with
um with some of the theory here black
goes b5 and in return for the
for the d5 square black gets a lot of
counter play
and this counter play comes in the
various types first of all there's a
threat of b4
um this knight on a3 is excommunicated
and eventually what usually tends to
happen is that
after a trade occurs on f6 as you'll see
black will move the bishop away from f6
where it will
appear um in fact let's see the next
couple of moves knight to d5 bishop b7
bishop f6 bishop f6 and one of black's
ideas is to move this bishop away and
then to go to f5 opening up the f file
and a lot of sebastian kopf games has
have been won when white gets too
enamored
with that square on d5 and forgets that
black has very significant play on
the uh on the king side uh connected
with this f5 move so it's a very very
theoretical opening white has a million
different ways to play it
and kasparov plays the main line the
most fashionable move of the time c3
and the idea of c3 is well there's a
couple of ideas it controls the d4
square
mainly it prepares to evacuate this
knight from the edge of the board with
knight
c2 after which white can then undermine
black's
pawn wedge with a4 so that's sort of a
very standard set of moves
and that's exactly what happens sherab
develops his darks a light squared
bishop kasparov goes
knight c2 this is still very much
extremely theoretical and sure goes
knight to b8
which is actually still remains a very
relatively popular move but i think back
then was the main line
and black extends the pressure on the
knight on d5
the knight from c6 uh to b8 can then go
to d7 where at least you know
it does a couple of things it can later
go to c5 and attack e4 it can also go to
b6
uh and contest the knight on d5 so it's
definitely a lot better placed and not
in the way as the knight
on c6 would be so this move might be one
of those gm moves that actually is a lot
more understandable than it looks
because sparrow
goes a4 um as we
you know which is the main line
undermining the pawn
the sheriff has to take and kasparov
takes with a rook
there's still over 150 games in this
position
so now kasparov sure was one of the
first high-level games to go into this
line
and it was played a couple of times
previously by
gm's uh but not too many times so this
was relatively unexplored territory
already by both players
now sure of well what to do he goes
knight t7 improving the position of his
knight
and kasparov goes
rook to b4 and we are about to enter
the main part of this game the moment
that made this game very very famous
okay so rogue before was played caspar
was the highest rated player was it a
novelty at the time this game was played
let me check
so it was i don't believe a novel chess
base could be stupid sometimes
oh god okay so we see rook before
had been played three times before
kasparov played it
uh most prominently by patrick wolfe um
who was former us champion now lives in
san francisco a good friend of mine
grand master he played it against an
early computer
uh actually so it was sort of kind of a
novelty
um and one very interesting thing
that uh you guys should be aware of uh
at high level chess novelties are very
big
when you manage to produce a novelty
that means you were the first person
obviously to play a certain move and
novelties can earn you a lot of currency
in terms of
being considered one of the sort of
leading opening theoreticians the people
who are considered opening
trailblazers are those who are able to
come up with new moves
in previously explored positions so
there's always this sort of
race to produce as many high quality
novelties as possible not all novelties
are high quality
some just kind of fall off the map um
yeah i i believe i did thank
abf chess appreciate the raid now was
there another raid
um if i if so i i apologize
now i don't know if this is interesting
to you guys i mean
there's 2 000 people watching i'm not i
know
it's late for most people but you know
let me know if i'm just droning on and
it's not interesting uh
but i and i truly mean that i'm not
fishing for compliments like if i'm if
i'm boring you to death
please please make that known so
one interesting thing is that during the
1990s
uh games were not readily available
right there was no chess space there was
no megabase
and so sometimes there were moves that
were called novelties
but they had been played years before in
some completely unknown game between
like two
random 1900s so now
we can actually test whether a move is
truly a novelty
uh but back then you know everything was
relative to the games that would be
published in what would be called chess
informants
which were compilations of top level
games that would be released as
a book uh four or five times a year or
even more
and i don't quote beyond that and
everybody would buy those informants
because that was the only way you could
prepare for your opponents
anyways rook before not a novelty
the idea to attack the bishop um
and other than kasparov
this move was essayed by somebody named
giuliani
in 2000 so i didn't know that in
addition being the mayor of new york
giuliani was a very high-rated
correspondence player
and yeah rudy rudolph giuliani is a
grand master of correspondence chess and
in 2000
while being mayor of new york he um he
actually
also played a lot of correspondence just
kidding this was not rudy giuliani this
was
a guy named sante giuliani who's a very
strong
correspondence player she's trolling um
in any case he also went for this line
which is a pretty big indicator that
it's a pretty high quality line
in any case um yeah i know everybody
believed me
so sheriff goes knight c5 uh bringing
his knight as we discussed to a good
square
and simultaneously protecting the bishop
and the novelty i believe
amazing and kasparov's next move was
still not a novelty
it had been played twice before by
players who were not very strong which
tells me
that they were correspondence players
now
my question to you and this is what made
this game famous
what did kasparov play and mainly what
is the idea
of this move that he played
so this is sort of the pivotal pivotal
moments
in the game got king e2 is
a little bit over the top
um yeah so a couple of you got it
there's a couple of recommendations
which we'll go through one by one
some of you suggested rook b6 which
makes sense in principle
um because it does i guess it applies
pressure on the d6 pawn
and i suppose that if you take the
knight you can take with a queen
and if queen takes rook then there's
queen takes a check
so somehow white is holding on to this
line but i don't even think that is
necessary i think black can simply go
i mean what can black do here rogue v6
is
it it seems very artificial to me that's
the only problem
i feel like the computer would indicate
some sort of
refutation here maybe simply bishop g5 i
mean you're not really threatening
anything
um so it's a little bit premature to go
into this kind of play
the move is indeed rook takes p7
exchange sacrifice and let me check
who were these guys who had played it
before kasparov
no kasparov was the first to play
because sparrow was the first in fact i
sorted it by year no he was not
richie and i have been a 1900 played
this move
and then a 2200 play this move and then
kasparov played this move but we don't
have the actual
months that these were played in i don't
know what month kasparov's game occurred
and
when those other two games in 1994
occurred my guess would be they had to
see the kasparov game like
for a 1900 to come up with this and play
it possible but
that would be pretty crazy um
in any case you know the concept of a
positional sacrifice
to a lot of club players is
very sort of mystical and it might seem
very foreign and kasparov does indeed
follow up
with b4
now i'm not going to pretend that
positional sacrifices are
easy to understand or they're not very
hard to
execute properly but they are
more understandable than some people
realize because so the move before yeah
the main idea is to restrict the knight
on b7 is completely out of the game
permanent um and well not permanently
but in order to re-enter the game it's
going to have to somehow
maneuver through d8 which is currently
occupied by the queen and
even on e6 it's not doing much so that
knight is going to be a problem piece
for a very long time the second thing
that
kasparov accomplishes is he gets control
permanently
of lights and this is truly permanent of
light squares
he eliminates black's light squared
bishop so now not only is his knight
unassailable on d5 but the bishop once
it comes out so let's say
c4 is going to dominate completely on
the light squares which not might not
seem important right now but it's going
to be important
moves and that is the essence of a
positional sacrifice is you
judge that whatever you're sacrificing
for is going to eventually become
important
perhaps more important than it appears
now some of you may be wondering what
happens if a5 trying to undermine the
spawn on b4 well there is no need to
move the spawn
in fact you can give a check on b5 the
king has to move now you can drive this
bishop into c6 i mean this already looks
very nasty and then
the simplest is i think just a castle
and white is
i mean you can just visually see the
complete domination yeah and the queen
has nowhere to go either so if you
wanted to liberate this knight on b7 you
could go queen december you can't do
that either
because there's the possibility of
knight p6 of the fork
so shirov is reduced to playing on the
other side of the board he goes bishop
g5
which is a very understandable move i
explained the idea of this move
previously black is eventually trying to
prepare the move f5
after castling and here kasparov
continues to play in very inspired
fashion
his next two moves are the product of
identifying his worst place piece and
improving it
but improving it in a very sort of
creative way there is a piece he has
that's not doing anything and
you might say well it's the bishop but
the bishop can be easily developed
later there is a piece that's you know
that's not doing anything and you would
kind of urgently like to involve it
and that is the knight on c2 so where do
we actually put that knight
where do we lead that knight
so knight ce3 allows black to take you
don't want to you don't want to trade
too many pieces here if you don't
have to yeah knight a3
and a3 is merely a transit point
um to c4 where the knight will park
itself
applying further pressure on the d6 upon
restricting black's position even
further
and it will be sort of well defended by
the bishop
um and i don't think this is the only
move i think
something like bishop c4 probably was
also okay
but you know there's a lot to analyze
here i'm pretty sure that kasparov
analyzed this at home
and there's a lot of specific detail
here that he factored in which we're not
concerning us with ourselves with right
now
so sheriff castles he goes knight c4 and
sure of goes a5 continuing to try to
open the position up and get space uh
and literally air for his pieces now
obviously kasparov
does not react to that which would be an
unthinkable positional mistake that
would lead
allow black to come to c5 which is
exactly what you're trying to avoid not
to mention
sort of hand the passpont to black sokka
sparrow ignores it with bishop d3 that's
a very important skill by the way just
to ignore what your opponent is doing
not react to it
uh and it's also important to point out
if shirov goes a4
and tries to bank on his past one what
does white now have
um and this shows the magic of
kasparov's way when all of your pieces
are activated
it's easier to employ your pieces for
crucial tasks
that kind of crop up all of a sudden so
what do we do
so we give a fork skis and we pick off
this pawn or we take the rook both of
which are
disastrous for black so sure decides to
take opening up the a phil at least he
gets the a file
okay obviously we take now notice that
the knight is still completely
restricted
gerard goes queen b8 um what is the
purpose of this move
again i've seen this game before but
it's been a long time so it's like i'm
looking at these moves for the first
time as well and
i'm not an well you might say i'm a
prophet but
i'm really not i'm sort of honestly
looking at it too now what i think he's
trying to do
uh is actually leave space for the
knight to go to d8 and then to e6
and and to d4 i agree with you yeah
exactly so
he's also eyeing this b4 pawn and saying
okay you know whatever moves the night
that the queen might be able to take it
uh very understandable and it may seem
like things are spiraling out of control
but kasparov senses that he needs to act
with a lot of urgency
although he has positional domination he
doesn't have forever and that's also a
very important thing to remember
if shirov eventually gets his knight to
f4 and trades the knight on d5 white's
compensation could very well evaporate
so kasparov begins to take immediate
action
uh to stir things up before shurib is
able to unwind
and he starts with the move h4 chasing
the bishop away understandable
bishop drops back to h6 now kasparov
activates further
the knight on c4 and jumps out to b6
sure responds by moving his rook to a2
and now i actually think is a very
instructive moment which can be used as
a lesson
a lot of players looking at this
position
would spend a couple of seconds then
they would play a move
relatively quickly which move is
tempting for white
yes knight d7 97 is very tempting
because it's a fork but
that is false hope because after queen
a7 you're actually helping black now
here's the point i want to make
sometimes even if you were to win the
rook it would still not be that good
but here you can't even take the rook
because of checkmate so you actually
helped black activate his pieces
kasparov instead plays the very measured
move castles eliminating
all tactical threats and now he's
completely wiped the slate clean
and he can fully focus on using his
knights and his positional superiority
to his advantage rook d2 by sure of
he's trying to stir things up but now
kasparov jumps to f3
defending the bishop you can see that
shirov's rook is annoying but it's kind
of stranded and it's operating alone so
it's not really
creating anything and after queen a7
which sure plays anyway
kasparov jumps out into the final
invasion here knight to d7
look at how this knight has maneuvered
from seat
from a3 to c2
then back to a3 to c4 to b6 into d7 and
at each
transit point it has achieved something
specific
um on d7 it is attacking the rook
and if the rook moves now we have
what i think is a relatively
straightforward
decisive invasion of the other knight
and here
i'm pretty sure that there's probably
multiple ways to win you could fork with
knight c6 but queen takes f7
just intuitively ah looks like it wins
and if you take the bishop
there is i think a quite a beautiful
crushing blow for white here find it
ah very very nice i mean this is
actually kind of a typical idea if you
solved a lot
but it's nice knight f8 it produces a
pleasurable you know sort of effect now
queen tree is unstoppable and if you
take
queen takes f8 so
that's it that would have ended the game
so sure desperately goes knight to d8
opening up a lifeline through to the
king side if you do the same thing now
that's actually a very clever move by
sheroff because he picks off the
seven night with his queen and he
attacks on f8 i did get to work with
shura for a couple of days but i was
already a gm
and he was never sort of my long-term
coach
so kasparov says okay no problem he
takes the rug he has re-established
material equality
while keeping all of the advantages of
his position
including the knight on d5 dominance
over the light squares and now a passed
pawn
and a horribly weakened black's king
so kasparov now uses the main asset that
has been created which is the pass pawn
and he pushes it
sure responds in this last-ditch attempt
to create problems with queen a3 which
he seems to succeed in doing because if
kasparov moves the bishop well
sheriff could take and he could put the
rook behind the passport and black may
still be worse but now the knight is
actually very very close to finally
activating itself
and something like this could easily
happen and white loses most of his
advantage
um and this is a stage of the game in
which a lot of people slip up it's the
stage where
you've played a great positional game
now you need to transition from
general positional considerations to
specific tactical action and that often
involves a tactical sacrifice
and a lot of people just aren't prepared
for that that was one of kasparov's
greatest strengths i think he was able
to switch
seamlessly between positional play
tactical play and he goes queen f5
he simply abandons the bishop and he
banks on his incredibly strong pieces
to deliver uh the crushing attack and
it's actually not that hard to calculate
if queen takes d3
you go queen to d7 and you know the king
is entirely
alone here if the knight moves well you
have check on c8 and this is just
checkmate
among other ways to checkmate there is
simply no defense if you play rook takes
c3
queen d7 and now if you try to bring the
queen back to a8
it's not hard to see that this is also
background checkmate i'm not using a
computer here so this is my own analysis
um so sheriff has to move his king to e8
in order to prevent the queen
from accessing d7 so now kasparov moves
his bishop away to c4
where it actively joins the attack by
x-raying f7
sure of pesters it with the rook c2 and
now essentially kasparov
finds uh not a difficult but a very
elegant um way to essentially end the
game he takes on h7
and we'll get to that in a second so
first i want to ask people what
is the final sequence of moves that
basically ends the game here
and in what order do you do it
just kid got it this is a tactic queen g
a check
king d7 knight b6
fork win the rook and in a very
fitting twist of irony white sacrifice
in exchange
and he ends the game and exchange up we
had a question about g6
in which position i assume in this
position
now was that the question uh yes
was it g6 here
oh on f8 okay
yeah so g6 i i guess queen f6 was the
intended response
and you're actually threatening both the
knight and checkmate so if the knight
moves you have checkmate
and you'll see that this is often the
case right when you're this week every
single pawn move creates
more holes so you solve one problem and
you create like five more
so sure did not resign here he moved his
king
takes the rook now because sparring for
another nightmare rookie one
this just shows you hitting the guy's
technique if you take the knight he goes
rook a7 check
and then he actually goes queen e8 check
and picks the knight off with check and
everything falls
so sure up goes queen d4 rook a3
still the knight is untouchable bishop
c1 and now
a very nice move knight e3 after which
sure resigns
the knight completes his victory tour if
bishop takes a3 you have a fork on f5
if black prevents it with g6 the knight
travels to d5
and the game is essentially over in a
million different ways
black's position collapses and sure i've
resigned after the move knight ethereum
of 38. i suppose if you take on e3
this is a very simple technical win a
very good choice coach grant um
yeah so that was the game and that just
shows you the seeming effortlessness
with which kasparov
won tournament after tournament in the
1990s and his opponent i remind you was
alexi alexis who at that point was
probably worth top five um and if you
think this was an anomaly
it was not kasparov won hundreds of
games
in this fashion just blowing his
opponent off the board with both colors
and it just appeared that these all of
these top gm's had no chances it was
like
it was decided from the beginning and
the critical point of this game of
course that exchange sacrificed very
forward thinking there were no computers
yet at the time so
if he did come come up with this on his
own it's still impressive
because to have the foresight to realize
you have enough compensation
uh to me is very very impressive
um and when you look at kasparov today
you have to realize that
he retired in 2005 it's been 15 years
since he played a classical game of
chess
um and to be thrust into a tournament
with
you know these monsters like magnus
takara who have been
literally playing for all these years
and are playing more now is
incredibly taxing and you see sparks of
the old kasparov
the problem is he's just unable to stop
the blunders which are natural but do
not forget
who this guy is and who this guy was
and who this guy should be remember what
this guy should be remembered by
um so um
in any case well there were controver
that is true
there was controversy between kasparov
and shirov
um and i am not denying that caspara was
capable of very obnoxious behavior
and actions that are questionable
to put in my only thousand bits from
heze
and that is we're very well known and
admitted by many people but
you know at the same time he was a
you know he he did a lot of good things
and i have very good recollections of
working with him
and you know he didn't do anything truly
egregious i think
so one should be charitable
given a genius of this type i think to
sort of
understand somewhat understanding but i
of course that is true i'm not denying
it
um and
indeed many players of great caliber
have very big egos and are
noxious indeed um
gary did plenty wrong but um nothing
particularly egregious and he played
so many brilliant games so i'm not going
to go into the controversies
but he had sort of a bit of a dispute
with sure up
he said some stuff about other gm's you
know it was minor stuff mostly but
um again what do you expect of someone
who has conquered the chess world in
this regard
um in any case so
legend absolute legend of the game and i
hope you guys enjoy the game
i hope you guys enjoyed the analysis